Міноборони Росії заявило про зрив за
їхніми словами великомасштабного наступу
ЗСУ На п'яти ділянках фронту на
південно-донецькому напрямку і нібито
навіть сам начальник генштабу Герасимов
у цей період перебував на одному з
передових пунктів управління
всього було задействована 6
механізованих всього було задіяно шість
механізованих та два танкових батальйони
противника метою противника був прорив
нашої оборони на найбільш вразливій На
його думку ділянці фронту своїх завдань
противник не досягнув успіху не мав у
результаті в білих та грамотних дій
східного угруповання військ втрати ЗСУ
склали понад 250 осіб особового складу
16 танків три бойові машини піхоти 21
бойову броньовану машину
на бойовая бронированная машина тим
часом управління стратегічних
комунікацій ЗСУ попередило що російською
окупаційні війська готують дезінформацію
про Контрнаступ і активізують свої
інформаційно-психологічні операції для
цього Росія має заготовлені відео та
фото які показують підбиту техніку
загиблих і полонених а також інші
фейкові матеріали про напрямки Контр
наступу і втрати українського війська
українські військові експерти вважають
Це через те що у російських військових
починають здавати нерви від постійного
очікування Контр наступу ЗСУ Це робиться
для того щоб просто створювати ілюзію що
Міністерство оборони збройних сил
Російської Федерації володіють
контролюють ситуацію що вони не
допустять то
наступу тому що у них є цілий
Пласт роботи по дискредитації
українського контернату і ви думаєте
операції яких ніколи не було і
приписуються собі героїчні вчинки він це
в принципі
конашенков на будує свою кар'єру ці всі
Віртуальна реальність паралельна коли
вони малюють знищення 10 патріотів 15
кальмарців кожного дня водночас
генеральний штаб збройних сил України
заявив що не володіє інформацією про
масштабний наступ який затвердженням
Росії розпочала Україна а Міноборони
України випустило відеоролик і в якому
українські військові закликають доти ще
заявивши що оголошення про початок
Контрнаступ не буде
Щодо цієї передбачуваної великої атаки
яка не була підтверджена Це невелика
масштабна Атака здається була задіяна
бойова група в Україні є десятки і
десятки таких бойових груп Протягом
наступних кількох тижнів і місяців ми
почуємо багато таких претензій і дуже
мало Я думаю зустрічних тверджень з боку
України позиція українців поки що така
ми нічого не говоримо поки чогось не
досягнемо і взагалі коли вони кажуть що
чогось досягли вони справді цього
досягли
гуся не зовсім правдивими
пам'ятаю тож можливо є ймовірні що
справді була спроба прориву російської
лінії оборони однак що стосується
масштабів цієї атаки та того факту що
російські війська відбили таку кількість
українських сил включаючи дві танкові
бригади це виглядає м'яко кажучи не
пропорційним
кажемо точно знати Тому що українська
сторона нічого не говорить зі зрозумілих
причин тому що вони не хочуть розкривати
плани однак Ми повинні сприймати це з
певною часткою скепсису принаймні до тих
пір поки ми не отримуємо якусь перевірку
відзнятих матеріалів і Дані від
української сторони
на тлі цієї війни дезінформації та
дезорієнтації рішуче контрнаступальні
дії ЗСУ можливі вважають опитані
дойчевельні військові експерти про
готовність України заявляв Президент
країни Володимир Зеленський аналітики
зазначають що це не буде так як
намагаються подати Міноборони РФ та
російська пропаганда
це не буде одним ударом це не буде одним
масованим наступом одним потужним
штурмом як у Першу світову війну бо
ризик провалу великий більший ймовірно
що це буде серія операції по всьому
фронту для виявлення слабких місць Росії
і це триватиме багато часу тому Нам не
слід очікувати швидкого розвитку подій
це тривала серія операції який ймовірно
лише розпочинаються
за даними військових експертів
Українські війська зараз майже по всій
лінії фронту промацують оборону росіян
йде розвідка боєм відволікаючий удари
маневри тому заяви Міноборони РФ про
зрив великомасштабного наступу ЗСУ
передчасні в цих умовах звісно треба
максимально заплутати противника що вона
наразі відбувається Ну наприклад на
бахмутському напрямку там ідуть досить
активні дії які в тому числі вражаються
в тому що в Україні українська армія
поступово просувається по флангах
відсікаючи російські війська від бахмуту
і створюючи умови саме для пастки самому
місці зайшла вже регулярна армія збро
йні ціни провели локальні наземні атаки
та можливо досягли обмежених тактичних
успіхів на заході Донецької та сході
запорізької областей про це йдеться у
щоденному огляді інституту вивчення
війни опублікованому в понеділок 5
червня як пишуть американські аналітики
геолокаційні кадри від 4 червня свідчать
що українські війська здійснили обмежене
просування на північний схід від
рівнополя на Донеччині
Це нам говорить про те що українці
намагаються вдарити по різних фронтах
тож повідомлялося про атаки в Запоріжжі
А так і на півдні Донецька
Отже українці намагаються проводити
стратегію тисячі скорочень як сказав
Михайло Подоляк Маючи на увазі що вони
шукають слабкі рубежі російської оборони
і намагаються побачити де вони можуть
прорватися щоб надіслати підкріплення
під час літнього контрнаступу за
оцінками військових експертів Україна
робитиме акцент на високоточних
артилерійських ударах далекобійних
ракетах розвідданих від союзників і
західній бронетехніці винищувачі f16 про
які так багато говорять останнім часом
за словами міністра оборони України
Олексій арезнікова влітку задіяні не
будуть Утім українські військові
погоджуються з інформаційною тишею щодо
контернаступу адже говорити про нього не
одне і теж що брати в ньому участь про
це наступу займає дуже багато дій і дуже
багато втрат дуже багато труда насправді
знаєте сказати просто по телевізору чи
десь одному експерту сказати що
проводиться Контрнаступ там успішно Там
неуспішно Там нас піджимають там ми
піджимаємся це дуже цікаво Да а
насправді прийдіть в окопи сходять на
один штурм сходіть на інший штурм
втримуйте оборону посидіть піддер-
артилерію не попийте води декілька діб
поїжте там тушонки бліндажі тоді Ви
зрозумієте як Воно проводиться поки ти
цього сам не спробуєш ти не зрозумієш